thank you thanks for the investment
it's good to be giving talks in person
actually
well
um
so um so I'm going to talk about the
Matrix completion problem which is
basically a problem that has been looked
at by statisticians and people in
machine learning and you know there is
something to say in terms of graph
limits graph runs uh so uh so maybe and
there are some open questions or maybe
something good will come out of this
talk I haven't given a talk on this
before it's a couple of years old
um so the problem of reconstructing a
large low rank Matrix from a subset of
revealed entries uh this has um you know
there are literally now thousands of
papers on this
um so so you have a large Matrix which
is assumed to be of low rank and only a
subset of entries are revealed and you
have to guess the rest so it comes from
this problem of you know recommended
systems where people give ratings and
you know low rank is sort of natural
assumption
um now it's uh if you think about it
it's just a problem in linear algebra
but if you look at the classical linear
algebra literature uh this um
The Matrix completion is restricted to
the matrixes with special structures
such as positive definite matrices
uh if you just assume low rank uh then
most of the modern literature
um assumes that a certain fraction of
Entry entries are missing uniformly at
random okay and uh so so you know it's
there's a 40-minute talks I'm not going
to talk about uh the review so much so
I'll give you the reference to my pepper
and you can you can look at a more
extended review and uh so this
assumption a missing uniformly at random
is is not realistic but uh you know you
can prove very nice theorems uh with
this and there are only a small number
of papers which work with uh
deterministic Missing patterns or
missing patterns that depend on The
Matrix so not uniformly at random uh so
um so this was the primary motivation of
the work that is uh you know if you just
consider the linear algebra problem if
you have a large Matrix so you assume
it's low rank and uh a certain pattern
of entries is missing uh when can you
approximately fill in The Matrix um you
know if you don't want to make any
assumptions about this missing
um uh you know what is missing or how is
it related to the data uh any model on
the missing um
perspective
so uh so I'll give you a complete
characterization I should say a
synthetic characterization of missing
patterns that allow approximate
completion of large lowering matrices
and this is from uh from this paper from
two years ago and this characterization
will be in the language of graph limit
Theory okay so so this will tell you
exactly what kind of missing patterns
allow completion of
of large low rank matrices
so uh so first of all you know just to
begin it's important to note that not
all patterns of revealed entries allow
low rank Matrix completion you know even
if you make the Assumption of low rank
uh and even if you just want completion
in an approximate sense you don't want
the exact Matrix back but only
approximately
um and even if a substantial fraction of
entries are revealed and this is a very
simple example so for example if you
have an N by matrix and you only reveal
the top n over two rows then there is no
way you can complete the you know bottom
n over two rows even if you assume the
Matrix is low rank you know that's just
impossible to do
so this uh this cannot be completed
means that there are multiple very
different ways to complete uh which are
all low rank you know so so this is not
this is not a missing pattern that you
can handle right in any reasonable way
so um
so any particular completion cannot be
reliable estimate of the Matrix if this
is the pattern of missing entries
now this example suggests that the set
of revealed entries has to be in some
sense dense in the set of wall electrics
so if there's a large you know Square
yeah
when you say computer Matrix
is it some criteria you want to complete
it yeah so low ranks so assume it's low
rank okay assume it's low rank but even
under the assumption even if you assume
it's it has rank one you cannot complete
this Matrix if this is the pattern of
missing entries that's the idea you want
to maintain yeah yeah so that's the
general Criterion that people uh have
assuming the literature
so so this suggests that the set of
revealed entries has to be dense in the
set of wall entries so if there's a
large you know empty box where
everything is missing then obviously
even on your low rank you cannot
complete it okay foreign
however one has to be cautious it's
considered the a second counter example
suppose n is even consider an N by a
matrix whose igf entry is revealed if
and only if I and G have the same parity
if both even or both are so this is a
kind of like a checkerboard pattern uh
so these are the revealed entries the
Shaded ones
so this um will argue that this is the
recovery is not possible even if the
rank of the Matrix is as small as three
okay and this is a pretty dense pattern
of entries
so what you do is again something very
simple uh you just permute rows and
columns so that the even numbered rows
um and columns are numbered from 1 to n
over two and the odd number draws and
columns are numbered from n over two
plus one to n and with this permutation
the missing pattern just becomes this so
although this looks dense here after
permuting rows and columns you get this
very large missing blocks okay so again
this becomes impossible to estimate uh
even if you assume low rank
so clearly this cannot be recovered
reliable even if the rank is uh as small
as three
um
questions
okay so so the problem with the second
example is that the rows and columns
could be relabeled so that the pattern
of revealed entries again is no longer
dense okay so that's so that's a problem
so this suggests that for recoverability
of low rank matrices it is necessary
that the pattern of revealed and remains
dense under any re-ribling of rows and
columns so however you relabel rows and
columns the missing entries should
always look
um dense in The Matrix that's that must
be necessary condition because if that's
not there then obviously you cannot
complete The Matrix it turns out that
this condition is also sufficient but
that's a little difficult to express and
that's one of the open questions how to
have a finite sample version of this
um so uh so this is the first main
theorem uh the precise statement I give
in the language of graph limit Theory so
so only as a limiting statement I can
give this so what what do I mean by
saying that under any permutation of
rows and columns the pattern of missing
entries remains dense and uh you know so
it should be very nice to have a finite
end version of that but I don't have I
have a limiting version of that and I'll
display that
and uh and so it turns out to be a
necessary and sufficient condition for
recoverability of um low rank matrices
and the second result is that uh well
this is a necessary and sufficient
condition but how do you recover The
Matrix what's an algorithm it turns out
that a nuclear minimization algorithm of
Candace and react uh this succeeds in
approximately recovering the full Matrix
whenever this condition holds so a small
modification so you basically have to
impose a supremum norm constraint as an
additional convex constraint and then it
turns out that this is always able to
recover approximately recovered The
Matrix whenever this condition holds so
not only is this this condition that I'm
going to present necessary and
sufficient for
um missing patterns which allow the
Matrix to be covered approximately there
is also a simple algorithm for doing it
okay so let me uh give the precise
statements first some Matrix Norms let a
B and M bind Matrix are all you know
real entries
we Define the average for minions Norm
as follows so you take the average value
of the sum of the squares of the Matrix
entries and take the square root so this
represents the sort of the in some sense
the average size of a matrix entry
uh if these are the non-zero singular
values the nuclear Norm is defined as
the sum of the singular values
the L Infinity Norm is just the maximum
Matrix entry
and finally the cut Norm I defined in
the following way you take the maximum
of X absolute value of x transpose to a
y where X and Y are vectors we tell
infinite unbounded by one should you
have absolute values
well I'm assuming singular values are
defined as non-negative so like the
square roots yeah so that's yeah yeah so
instead of eigen values you have
singular values
so um and the cut Norm is a maximum of
absolute X transpose d y where X and Y
are vectors of L and three Norm bounded
by one and I divide by 1 over m n for a
certain normalization well this will not
be important
so so these are various Matrix norms
and um uh you know this one in
particular uh will be useful in our
statements this is this it is a measure
of the average size of the Matrix entry
so if this is small you know that the
Matrix has small elements
uh another thing that I need to Define
is the cut distance between two matrices
so let s n be the group of all
permutations of one up to n
and for any two permutations pi and Tau
and the Matrix a let a pi Tau be the
Matrix whose um igf entries a pi I Tau J
so you apply pi and Tau to permute the
rows and columns and you permute this
Matrix and then the current distance
between two M by matrix is a and b uh is
uh you know you take the minimum over
all permutations of rows and Columns of
a and subtract B from that and take the
cut Norm so you basically you're
permuting rows and columns to make the
matrices as close to each other as
possible in the cut Norm so that's the
cut distance so this is
and this is all from from graph limit
Theory
X norms
okay so
um next uh we'll say a matrix is a
binary Matrix if it's entries are zero
or one and we'll use binary matrices to
denote the locations of revealed entries
in Matrix completion problems
so so where are the missing uh entries
uh so those are zeros and uh available
entries are are one
had about product so sorry about so much
terminology but I know that's about I
need the minimum I need so if a and b
are two M bind matrices the haremon
product is just uh entry-wise product so
it's another mine Matrix who's uh you
know and uh and and the way I use
I use a binary Matrix
of the revealed entries then the
hadamard product of A and P is the
matrix's entries are equal to the
entries of a whenever they're revealed
in zero elsewhere okay so this is a
simple notation that uh
makes it easy to write down things
okay so so let me now give you the
notion of uh when I say certain patterns
allow you to recover entries so let me
make that precise
um so certain patterns of rebuild
entries may not suffice for
approximately covering your full Matrix
whereas other patterns specifies so this
makes some sense intuitively but to give
a precise definition
um you know
um we we take this approach so what we
say is that approximately recovery means
that if two low rank matrices
are approximately equal on the revealed
entries there should also be
approximately equal everywhere okay so
again I'll make this completely precise
but this is what I mean by saying that
um
uh you have uh you have recoverability
approximately recoverability uh where I
mean that if you have two low rank
matrices which are approximately equal
on the revealed entries then they should
also be approximately equal everywhere
and this is not true in the two counter
examples I showed so you can have two
low rank matrices which are
approximately equal under all the
repealed entries but they are very
different in the unrevealed entries
um no no just you know just low rank
just lowering
but not necessarily equal rank
so uh to make this fully precise
um and to capture all possibilities I
need a limiting statement okay so if I
have a finite statement I will have to
restrict myself to some smaller class
you know something so so I don't want to
do that so that's why I need a limiting
statement so here is the definition it's
a little long so let PK be a sequence of
binary matrices possible different
dimensions typically will take
increasing dimensions
um we'll say that this sequence admits
stable recovery of low rank matrices if
it has a following property take any two
sequences of matrices AK and B K where
for each k a can become the same
dimensions as p k
and suppose the ranks and the L Infinity
Norms of these sequences of matrices are
uniformly bounded so okay so you have
two sequence of matrices with uniformly
bounded ranks uniformly bounded L
Infinity norms and then it should be
true that for any Epsilon there is some
Delta so that if the average size of the
entry revealed entries in the two
matrices differ on average by less than
Delta in a limiting sense
then the average size average difference
of the entries everywhere
should all should be less than Epsilon
okay so so if they are small on the
revealed entries uh if the difference
between the two matrices are small and
the revealed entries and the matrices
have ranks and elements uniformly
bounded
then uh the matrices themselves should
be close to each other
so this is a limiting statement which
which captures uh all possibilities
without speaking of any rates of
convergence I know if you have if you
give a finite definition you know maybe
there is some way but you know I
thought about it in terms of just fixed
matrices and there is no sensible
doesn't seem to be a sensible way to um
to capture this uh this idea so this
this seemed to me to be the only way to
do this
but I may be wrong so um
any questions about this definition
yeah you know some fixed Eminem
so so each PK has some Dimension call it
MK cross n k and you know M K and N are
typically going to Infinity but I don't
need that in definition but you know in
examples yes
no so I don't want them to be equal on
the revealed entries I want them to be
approximately equal in the revealed
Matrix yeah can you comment on that oh I
see yeah so so that's that's an
important thing so if they're exactly
equal on the revealed entries uh it's uh
you know it's uh so so this this is I
I'll have I have a remark about that so
this is why actually stable recovery
so so if you do if you assume that
they're exactly equivalent reveal
entries the situation is a bit different
than when you say that they're
approximately equal so stability means
that even if they're approximately equal
you can deduce that they're
approximately equal everywhere you don't
need exact quality
that is you allow this sequence of mud
is growing and nothing is dependent of
the dimension of matrices this means
that when
if you take this limit and the matrices
are growing and you have this Mountain
Way for business Norm which means that
then each entry will be very close right
no so this is bound on the average
Province Norm so so F Bar
as I wrote down here it's normalized by
the dimension yeah it's normalized by
the number of entries so the average for
minutes Norm denotes the approximate
average size of the energy
not not the province now
so uh so we'll say that uh this sequence
of binary matrices is admit stable
recovery of low rank Matrix if this is
true for any two sequences of matrices
with uniformly bounded ranks and
infinity Norms you can have this okay
so uh so to show that
that does not admit
it's one country example and uh so so
this is the remark that I said the word
stable is added to definition the
emphasize that we need only approximate
equality of the revelatories rather than
exact equality
and the two examples discussed earlier
you can very easily produce counter
examples to show that they do not admit
stable recovery okay so uh so now you
know it you can make a precise sense of
what I just said earlier that this will
not allow you to recover you have for
each and you have a missing pattern and
then you can produce a sequence of low
ranked matrices uh where you know they
are equal you can actually get exactly
equal on the revealed entries but uh you
know the average difference if you
consider all entries that is not going
to zero
okay so um
so to verify that a sequence at which
stable recovery of low rank matrices we
need to verify that the student
condition holds for all sequences of
matrices AK and B K but it would be much
more desirable to have an equivalent
criteria in terms of some intrinsic
property of this sequence itself
okay instead of verifying it for all AK
and B K so this is what we're aiming for
and our first main result gives such a
Criterion to State this result we need
the language of graph limit Theory so
I'll just State a few things and many of
you are familiar with that so in graphic
material graphone is a boreal measurable
function from the unit squared to 0 1
which is symmetric in its argument
and you were dealing with matrices that
may not be symmetric so we need to
generalize the definition by graphing
the symmetric condition so we Define
an asymmetric grapher as a broiler
measurable function from the unit square
into zero one without
the condition of
condition of symmetry okay so just
that one
now if W is an asymmetric graph one and
M and N are two positive integers to
define the M by n distribution of w to
be the M by matrix whose igf entry is
the average value of w in this rectangle
so so you take the unit Square you
divide into M by n little pieces and on
each piece you take the average value of
w and then you define a matrix
and if a is an M by matrix and W is an
asymmetric graph on WE Define the cut
distance between a and w to be the cut
distance between the Matrix a and this
disposition of w okay
uh so this is just you know I just
defined this like this and there can be
um
other ways of defining this but I'm just
depending this letter
uh we'll say that the sequence converges
to an asymmetric graph on W A sequence
of matrices if this cut distance goes to
zero as K goes to Infinity
so so a sequence of matrices will
converge to an asymmetric graph one if
this happens
and note by the same sequence they
converge to many different limits and in
graph limit typically all these
different limits are considered to be
equivalent by defining equivalence
relational space of graph runs and we
can do the same for asymmetric reference
but you know we don't need to worry
about that right now we can think of
um this as you know you organize the
Matrix permute the rows and Columns of
the Matrix in such a way that you know
it converges to some reasonable image
so um
so we'll use asymmetric Graphics
represent limits of binary matrices
and not every sequence of binary
matrices will have a limit but this the
following result which is a standard
thing in graph limit Theory uh but you
know I didn't see it written down for
asymmetric things uh you know maybe
there is somewhere uh so any sequence of
binary matrices with Dimensions standing
contagious has a subsequence that
converges to a symmetric graphon and
this is the asymmetric analog of a
compactness of a fundamental compactness
theorem in graph limit Theory due to low
price and secondly uh so so you can
always have subsequential limits given
any sequence of um binary matrices you
can have subsequences converging to
asymmetric graph one and any
substitutions subsequence and so on
so so the reason I stick this result
um
is that uh we want to give a necessary
and sufficient condition for a sequence
of binary matrices to admit stable
recovery of low rank Matrix so this is
our goal yeah so you need all the rows
and columns rotation when you say
Dimensions yeah both rows and columns
uh so uh so you want to give an
essential and sufficient condition for a
sequence of binary matrices to admit
stable recovery of low rank matrices
and because of the compactness theorem
uh we it suffices to only consider
convergent sequences because in any
sequence of binary matrices we'll have
convergent sequences subsequences and so
so we can only state we can State the
theorem just in terms of convergence
sequences of binary matrices
so here is the first main result
um a sequence of binary matrices with
Dimensions tending to infinity and
converging to an asymmetric graph on W
admin stable recovery of low rank
matrices if and only if W is non-zero
almost every word just specular magnet
so this is what it means when I see the
finite statement that you have a missing
pattern where any permutation of rows
and columns will keep it dense you can
never get a large block of empty entries
and the the limiting version of that is
that this matrices are converging to an
to a limiting graph on which is non-zero
almost everywhere and graphones as I
said are equivalent under you know
measurable bijections of um the two
coordinates and this condition being all
non-zero almost everywhere is preserved
under that so it's a characteristic of
the equivalence classes okay so so this
is the necessary and sufficient
connection
so you're allowing for low rank matrices
but you're not allowing for sparse
matrices right yes I'll give a comment
about that so what what is what is going
on with sparse matrices
uh non-zero almost every wish is sort of
saying it's uh very dense right I mean
it's you have no Open Spaces really yeah
no Open Spaces
foreign
so this is this is just a condition on
the missing patterns so if a sequence of
missing pattern satisfies this condition
then
um and then you have two sequence of
lower any two sequence of low rank
matrices so low rank meaning uniformly
bounded Rank and I'm assuming uniformly
bounded L Infinity Norm two sequences of
such matrices which are approximately
equal on the revealed entries of this
sequence of binary matrices then they
must also be approximately equal uh
everywhere
in a certain sense this is saying that
the revealing should be independent of
the Matrix right yeah yeah and that you
don't allow for these dependencies yeah
so so this is so so you can use it uh so
I I have used it uh with one of my
students I'll give a remark about that
later on where you know the probability
of an entry being missing depends on the
entry and you can have all kinds of
complicated things so you can have very
complicated missing patterns as as long
as you can prove the limiting graph run
is non-zero almost everywhere
you are done so the case of uniformly
missing at random is a very simple case
whether limiting graph on is just a
constant
and so it holds in that case but it does
not need to be that it can be something
extremely complicated that depends on
the Matrix and depends on the data yeah
I don't have a really good intuition for
this asymmetric Graphics is that
equivalent set some
version of subcarf counts has to be
non-zero for every subgraph so I I could
not do it with this subgraph approach so
the way I proved the compactness theorem
is is by adapting the spectral proof uh
you know using the Spectrum so using
singular values instead of eigen values
so uh so you know I I don't know how it
translates uh in terms of sub graph
counts
I guess there may be some way of doing
it with bipartite graphs but I but the
question is is there some way to say
that there are that this WB non-zero
probably related
yeah I don't know that so so my I
visualize this as saying that you know
no matter how you permute the zeros and
ones the ones always you cannot somehow
come up with some black regions
foreign
things with the frobenius average
frobenius norm do you have a sense of
what happens if there and are there
other meaningful Norms that one should
consider and and how does that change
yeah one can one can consider uh I would
think that you know any Norm which sort
of measures the average size of the
entries uh should give the same result
but something like the spectral Norm
will be different so so that would be
thank you uh and just to clarify is
there any assumption that the dimensions
are going to infinity or anything like
that or yeah so yeah so we Dimensions
yeah
foreign
okay so uh so to understand this result
first consider the case of entries
missing uniformly at random as I said so
suppose that each entry is revealed
would probably be independently of each
other
then the corresponding sequence of
binary matrices converges to the graph
one that is identically equal to p
and if this p is positive the theorem
tells us that the sequence of these
patterns admits a stable recovery of low
rank matrices which is a well-known
result
on the other hand consider the example
where only the top half of the rows are
revealed this will converge to the graph
one that is um one on this rectangle
zero half zero one and zero in half one
cross zero one and this is uh there's a
positive region where it's zero so this
does not require admit stable recovery
of low rank matrices
so here is the attack
I have already pointed out that uh one
may be puzzled by the fact that this
theorem implies that stable recovery is
impossible if the set of revealed
entries is sparse because a limiting
graph on is is identical zero whereas
there are many existing results about
recoverability of low rank matrices from
a sparse set of revealed entries okay so
the the issue is that we are not
assuming Randomness and at the same time
demanding that the recovery is stable
okay that is the reason so so what
happens is that suppose you have two low
rank matrices and most entries are the
same for the two matrices but the
entries differ uh that differ are only
the ones that are revealed okay so since
you are not assuming that the pattern of
revealed entries is uniformly at random
uh we're not assuming anything about it
it may be that uh
only the bad places are revealed you
know where the matrices are different
and then there is no way to tell that
the matrices are mostly the same okay so
if you don't assume Randomness you run
into this problem that you can't have uh
you know and and only a sparse set of
entries are revealed you can have this
problem that you you know the matrices
are different just on that sparse set
and and that's why the stable recovery
is impossible from a small set of
revealed entries if there is no
Assumption of Randomness so so if you
want uh you know recovery of low rank
matrices
from us part set of entries you have to
maybe uniformly at random is not
necessary but I would think that some
assumption will be necessary you you
cannot just have an arbitrary
deterministic thing because you can just
reveal a small set of bad injuries
instead of making Randomness assumption
if we have assumption like finite Rank
and there'll be the Gap in the spectrum
of the uh missingness under those
conditions can one prove some results
yeah I think there is some literature on
uh on expander type uh you know missing
patterns uh expand them yeah so
it's in the paper
okay so the next thing is um how to
recover The Matrix so so the theorem
gives an intrinsic characterization of
recoverability in terms of the locations
of the revealed entries
however it does not tell us how to
actually recover The Matrix when the
revealed and when recovery is possible
so suppose you know that that recovery
is possible how do you recover The
Matrix
so fortunately it turns out this is this
is doable by a small modification of an
algorithm that is already used in
practice
uh this is the algorithm of kindness and
react
um of a partial reveal entries is the
Matrix with minimum nuclear Norm among
all matrices that agree with a at the
revealed entry so suppose you have a
matrix which is revealed only partially
uh then you look at all matrices which
agree with this Matrix add the revealed
entries and you take the one that
minimizes the nuclear Norm because
that's the kind of direct algorithm and
it works very well for Miss uniformly at
random and it even works well it makes a
uniformly at random and but only a small
set of you know sparse set of entries
um so so this is a modification uh so
that a b a matrix whose entries are
partially revealed and suppose we have
some additional information we know that
the L Infinity Norm is bounded by L for
some known constant L and this is not
unrealistic in in most practical
problems we'll know some some bound on
the entries
uh we Define the modified estimator of a
as a matrix that minimizes nuclear Norm
among all B that agree with a at the
revealed entries and satisfies uh this
uh L Infinity bound on The Matrix
entries so these are both context
constraints so it's a convex problem so
it should actually I think
an option already exists in the r code
you know if you want to have the
have the entries bounded so so you just
find find a matrix which agrees with
with your given Matrix at the revealed
entries and uh it has the same L
Infinity Norm upper bound and minimizes
the nuclear Norm among all such matrices
so this is your estimator
okay
so um so as I said the Assumption of
known upper bounded electric Norm is not
unrealistic usually such upper bounds
are known and the modified estimator is
a solution of a pandex optimization
problem just like the original estimator
and so
um and I I think the code exists so
because my student was able to yeah
to do it uh so
the dimensions are not too large so the
following theorem is the second result
of this talk shows that this modified
can distract algorithm is able to
approximately cover the full Matrix
whenever the pattern revealed entries
allows stable recovery
so this is the theorem let PK be a
sequence of binary matrices with
Dimensions standing to Infinity that
admits stable recovery of low rank
matrices so this already you are
assuming this that this is a sequence uh
which admits stable recovery of low rank
matrices and we we know a Criterion for
that stated earlier
let AK be a sequence of matrices so that
for each K AK has the same dimensions as
PK
suppose that rank an electricity norm
and uniformly bounded and an upper
boundary term is known
let a hat K be the modified
Counter-Strike estimate of AK when the
locations of the revealed entries are
given by PK
so then the average frobenius norm tends
to zero
so this can distract why do you insist
on this upper boundary no uh well
because that's in the modified algorithm
uh that uh that we have to use
um
the upper bound to get the estimate so
I'm I'm looking I'm I'm given a matrix
with partially revealed entries and
looking at all matrices which agree with
the with the with the given Matrix add
the revealed entries and satisfies this
L Infinity upper bound and then minimize
nuclear Norm among all such matrices
so it's in the algorithm so otherwise
you can have some some issues uh where
you can have uh you know small L
Infinity Norm but one entry can become
very large and then it destroys this um
average rubinious norm so that kind of
issue can come up
so
that's the uh upper bound L appear in
the air uh when something converges to
zero so so there is no error there is
you know it's just limiting statement
yes yeah but let's look at the pre-limit
does that depend on L
well it's from graph limit uh Theory so
that's uh you know okay abstract okay
so it's not something that can be
say hello
um when you use this uh nuclear Norm you
you have to still minimize overall
permutations right
so so you just you you are just given a
matrix with some entries are revealed
some are hidden the question marks so
you just look at all matrices which
agree with your given Matrix at the
revealed entries
and any arbitrary values at the missing
entries and then you uh with this
constraint that additional constraint
that the entries are bounded by this l
and then you minimize nuclear not among
all such and that's it that's all you
don't have to do all permutations or
anything I see so the only but you also
have two uh what about the rank uh no
you don't have to worry about the rank
you just so you will not necessarily get
a lowering Matrix not necessarily you'll
not necessarily get fluoride
okay uh so this is uh if there are many
other questions
okay and here's an application so
um so you know I don't know enough
programming to do this but then in a
follow-up work
um uh so consider a setting where uh the
probability that the entry is missing is
an unknown function of the value of the
entry so that's the simplest kind of
complexity above uniformly at random
maybe one can imagine
and uh so we wrote this follow-up paper
with my student Sean voltage area
um where uh under ellipse assumption on
this unknown function uh we um
we could show that the modified
estimator Works uh the
The Good the best thing about this paper
perhaps is that you know Sean was able
to actually uh carry this out on the
computer and it works really well so so
you if you have some function uh and the
probability of missingness is a function
of the Matrix entries uh you know we
have pictures where you know the the
function is is very accurately recovered
um so the results presented here were
key to the proof in this paper also
okay so there's some open problems uh
the definition of stable recovery
entails that the revealed entries are
only approximately equal to the
corresponding entries of the unknown
Matrix so if we drop this condition the
revealed entries are exactly equal to
the true entries how should the theory
be modified okay so do you get something
different do you get some some
additional because this is better that
if we exactly know the revealed entries
so so maybe maybe we can get something
more
I don't know uh this is a thing that has
been bugging me for a long time and this
is actually the original thing that uh
Sherman ice wanted to do but um we
couldn't uh developing non-asympotic
versions of this theorem is extremely
desirable so uh so it's not quite clear
what should the proper non-asentotic
statements that can that one can aspire
to prove uh you know one measure of this
thing is that uh suppose you have a
pattern of missing entries then you look
at the largest sub-metrix that's
completely missing so largest maybe
number of entries in terms of number of
entries and uh and can one use that as a
measure and get a get a finite sample
error bound uh you know just in terms of
that largest completely missing sub
Matrix okay so that would be extremely
nice to have uh and uh you know I don't
know how to do that
so if you put that in the framework of
graph limit Theory at least for
symmetric version there is
I mean except for this compactness
argument about the existence of a
convergent subsequence but everything
else in the theory of graph limits is
done explicitly I mean your errors may
be e to the one over Epsilon squared or
something like that but no but but the
problem is that so if I couldn't do so I
wouldn't look at how many interests a
zero I would look at the distance from
the zero Matrix in the cut metric
yeah and if that is bounded uniformly in
and From Below that's probably as good
as then you could argue if you had to
limit the subsequentially but it can't
be zero otherwise you would have a
contradiction so why can't you just put
plugin say okay I assume this is bounded
below so some Epsilon and now you do
your whole Theory I mean it's 200 Page
papers you have to go through but and
reduce them for the non-symmetric case
but I don't quite see where you
unless you're using in more places
compactness where you sort of just have
no control of the errors but if you put
the same already lemmas and stuff you
should get explicit errors no yeah I I
should get but the problem is that in
this convergence of this uh PK the
missing pattern to this limiting graph
on
I have to assume something about this
rate of convergence you know so that's
that's the
that's the problem that I couldn't uh
quite didn't quite know what to do uh
you know uh you know how close is your
missing pattern entry uh you know
missing pattern Matrix to the limiting
graph on I mean it's the same reason why
uh there you know as far as I know there
is no finite sample a version of the
oldest Hoover theorem you know so so the
older super theorem will tell you that
there is a if you have a row column
exchangeable uh infinite Matrix there is
a function f so that um
you know the xig is f of u i u j u i j
but if you actually want to get your
hands on this F so you know unlike
definitive theorem there is no
um finite version of of all the super
theorem uh as far as I know and it's the
same reason that uh
that you need to assume something about
the rate of convergence
otherwise uh yeah so so you know
I don't I don't know I couldn't couldn't
do anything that's that's all I did say
I mean as you said you would have
converged the subsequences but your
statement
so why would you need convergence if
your if your pattern Matrix
is just let's say uniformly bounded away
from zero in the cut Norm
okay
well if you want to assume a subsequence
at convergence but why do you even need
to I mean your serum doesn't in the end
have it right you just need that this
cut metric is sort of bounded away from
zero then any subsequence would convert
to a non-zr matrix but in your serum
you're never in the end you always said
without loss of generality but you don't
have to assume convergence right so
wouldn't your statement
just hold without the convergent
assumption so so that's that's also uh
also interesting uh so
so there are two theorems in the first
theorem
in the first theorem uh I I am assuming
that the binary Matrix is converging to
an isometric reference and then uh then
I say that you know uh this sequence of
binary Matrix is admit stable recovery
even only if uh W is non-zero almost
everywhere
um so that's that's in the first theorem
uh but so as you said your CM has
immediate caller is that it holds so
assume I had this Matrix
so assume I have this Matrix of zero
ones it's bounded Away In The Cut metric
from zero okay
so now I claim your CM holds why well I
choose the subsequence on the
subsequence it will converge that will
converge to a non-zero graph one so on
that subsequence it holds now you go to
another sub you will do the same thing
and so you know by your serum and using
subsequences your CM actually holds if
your sequence of pattern Matrix is
bounded away from zero in the cut note
uh but the thing is uh you know I'm not
assuming that W is uh
away from zero in the cut Norm I'm
assuming the W is a non-zero almost
everywhere so it cannot it's the same no
cannot even have a small region uh where
it's zero
you know it cannot even have uh you know
any any setup any set of yeah so so it's
so there's well so this comes sort of
back to my previous question right it
says some more combinatoric way of
characterizing
this non this sort of as you call it
yeah that's the open question
okay all right so uh so this is uh
this is the the open question uh so so
this this condition that the the the
this revealed entries uh this Matrix is
close to a graph one which is non-zero
almost everywhere you know how can you
quantify that you know that's that's so
that's the thing that I don't know how
to do I'll just do three more small open
problems um uh developing a version of
the theory that works for sparse we will
reveal matrices you have to make some
additional assumptions for sparsely
reveal matrices
um
so one thing that was not clear to me if
is if this algorithm indeed needs to be
modified I think the infinity bound is
important but I couldn't prove it uh it
would be nice if the original version is
good enough but you know it's not hard
to code even with this additional
constraint so not a big deal uh the
other problem is that this this
algorithm is rather slow for a very
large matrices it's a context
optimization problem if you have huge
Matrix then it's not a good thing to use
uh is there a faster algorithm maybe
using some Spectrum or something else
which can take its place and give the
same result that it works whenever the
recovery is possible
okay thank you
thank you very much for this beautiful
talk there
has already been a lot of discussion but
we can continue now
all guys first
thank you thank you very much for a nice
talk actually I have to be puzzled about
valgrave so can this taus condensation
algorithm is about the exact recovery so
this is why they're asking what is equal
to absurd entries and then in your
definition you have a proximate recovery
right and then uh the algorithm is
called Matrix lasso exactly the same
constraint on the soup Norm will
minimize the release squares plus the
nuclear knob doing it really with
exactly quality of the entries or you do
need this relaxed form of estimator so
so in the in the the algorithm that I
stated I am
um you know I'm considering all matrices
which exactly fit the revealed uh
entries but um the theorem tells you
that the The Matrix will be
approximately recovered even if the
revealed entries are slightly noisy but
I'm asking about to algorithm so the
condition algorithm so you you relate to
version of this algorithm once from the
original paper where they're looking for
exact recovery and then they said so my
Matrix equal to what I observe and there
is this other version you take the least
squares so you're looking for a best fit
penalized by the nuclear normal yeah so
I'm looking at the original version so
here is uh
um
so I'm just taking exactly revealed uh
so exact so I'm not not taking the noisy
version so so the the reason is that
even if there is noise you know this um
I'm assuming that noise is extremely
small so uh so you know I I have
approximately the revealed entries are
approximately the same as the original
entry so so
holiday
s
yeah
no I didn't understand so
yeah
you have enough noise
uh yeah bounded noise but I you know but
basically this Delta and Epsilon are
small that's the that's the thing so so
the Epsilon will depend on uh
Epsilon will depend on Delta if you take
Delta small Epsilon Epsilon will be
small in particular if Delta is zero
then uh you know Epsilon will also be
zero so
Epsilon will depend on Delta so it's uh
continuity kind of result
so coming to the question of spectral
algorithms at the end of your talk so
what so if I am trying to apply say
Universal singular value thresholding
algorithm so what would be like the most
General condition would you expect under
which so so Universal singular value
thresholding uh unfortunately will not
work so in my privilege home we have
proposed a modified version of that
which will work under this particular
setting where
um The Matrix entries are functions of
uh uh so so so the so so Universal
singular valves in Universal singular
valves thresholding it's important that
the missing pattern is um
the pattern of missing entries is
uniform at random if it's non-uniform
you have to modify the algorithm
the good thing about the current
District algorithm is that uh as I found
while working on this paper that it
works even if you have completely you
know non-uniform missing patterns
and um and so so I think it's more
generally true so what is presented here
is is one version of that but it's
probably true in much greater generality
to the contest reacting nuclear normally
musician just works for completely
non-uniform
experts
thank you very much
[Applause]
there's coffee and tea now and we
reconvene